are you I'm I am so excited is such a
wonderful evening we get to celebrate
art and everybody dresses up and has a
good time it's wonderful and you got to
be feeling so good because the reaction
from this film I mean I don't even need
to tell you but it's tremendous you know
I I'm so grateful to be a part of this
film and I'm so happy to see it getting
the reaction that it is you know all
that you ever want is for art to touch
people's hearts and Bradley Cooper
really made a film that is touching
people's hearts and I'm honored to be
the first actress in his directorial
debut you know it's wonderful and and
also to be nominated for shallow for
this song that I wrote with Mark Bronson
and Anthony Russell mundo and Andrew
Wyatt for the film how great is that he
you guys can say you got Bradley Cooper
his first Grammy nomination I love it
he's a musician he's he he not only sang
live the whole time but he also wrote
his own songs for the film I mean he's
really really brilliant and I I knew it
from the moment that we spent time
together that's what I want to know
about because I understand like from the
moment that you guys met and he came
over to your house right you guys just
hit it off what was it that we saw on
film the chemistry what was it when you
guys first met well besides the fact
that we you know ate some spaghetti
together and bonded as net you could use
coasters you know when we sang together
and talked about art and music we just
had a really strong connection and I
trusted him he's a really kind person
and when you have that I just I think
art can't fail when you have that trust
and I'm so grateful that we had that and
that that happened and I
and I'm I'm just happy to be here that
this is a beautiful night and I so I so
much want him to be honored for his
beautiful work they both deserve to be
honored it's just amazing and we gonna
talk about this amazing dress
oh it's phenomenal I understand it was
inspired by Judy Garland this is true oh
look you know what I don't I and we
didn't say that no but it it looks an
awful lot like that she looks beautiful
stars boring no with this this is
Valentino couture creation for me
costume yeah I mean but maybe you're
like okay with that yes I'll go with
this why not that's special except I'm
missing the gloves oh yeah
well we'll just need to go buy you a
pair a pair of long like love's right I
know what you might be so much showing
me that made my night I love Judy
Garland you understand your fiance is
with you tonight
yes he's here he's here he's wonderful
did that make the night even more
special of course to share it with the
one that you love you know it's just a
beautiful evening and he was so
supportive through the entire filming
process and you know I loved him very
much
What did he say to you about tonight is
he just so proud he said enjoy yourself
that's it he said yes you got any plans
that you could tell us about the big day
no come on Gaga sorry
I love the tube all right but I did hear
they were good to use I just don't have
any gloves to do it with
I understand you had a burger in fruit
loops last night though is that true for
Fruity Pebbles and also some Vietnamese
food I had to really pack it in before a
long evening you know and you look like
that before a run yeah I'm jealous you
look like this you know what women eat
eat what you want eat what you want do
what you want be who you are do not
starve yourself live your life you know
listen to Gaga I love you I love you
even more now it's you know listen I'm
telling you the pressures that Hollywood
and that you know celebrity or puts on
young people is too much and you know
it's like eat what you want be who you
are good for you and congratulations
because you were just beyond phenomenal
thank you
[Music]